figaro live 16h09 oui bonjour bienvenue
nous sommes en direct en direct pour
découvrir ensemble le casting du nouveau
blockbuster macron 2 et oui parce que
c'est imminent dans quelques minutes
nous connaîtrons la composition du
gouvernement j'ai envie de dire enfin
jeudi devait être bon jour est un peu
long grand reporter au figaro magazine
j'accueille également philippe guibert
essayer de vous un connaisseur de la
politique française alors dans un
instant nous serons à l'elysée on attend
alexis colère qui est le secrétaire
général de l'elysée il va venir sur le
perron et annoncé un gouvernement
pourquoi ça a été si long 26 jours on
n'a jamais vu ça après l'élection 26
jours après l'élection n'a jamais vu ça
je dis ça a été très long parce que ça
convenait emmanuel macron qui était
assez content de faire pour la campagne
et législatif qui l'a fait avec succès
pour la campagne de la présidentielle
c'est à dire la raccourcir dans le temps
le plus possible évitez de désigner des
ministres à la vindicte des oppositions
puisqu'on est en campagne législative
une histoire inconnue ministre protégées
dont tous plaidé pour qu'il retarde au
maximum
la nomination du gouvernement il aurait
presque pu la retarder encore davantage
mais peut-être que ça se serait vu et
puis il faut pas oublier qu' un casting
c'est toujours compliqué donc tout n'est
pas de son fait il ya eu aussi d'après
ce qu'on en sait des hésitations
sur sur l'identité des futurs de minuit
alors en attendant cette annonce on va
essayer de se projeter de savoir les
premières infos les freins vraiment mais
comment ça se passe quand on compose
d'un gouvernement non appel et alors
tout peut changer au dernier moment il y
aller jusque dans la dernière heure et
les ministres qu'on fallait apprendre
leur nomination en direct la division
etc ont reçu un coup de fil juste
quelques minutes avant ça c'est ça s'est
vu ce pas forcément un signe d'une
grande préparation dans la composition
du gouvernement mais ça a existé
historiquement ces dernières années
oui on reçoit un coup de fil mais ce
qu'on attend de ce gouvernement parce
que judith a évidemment raison c'est
quand même qui nous donne
éventuellement un début de souffle
mêlant pour ce nouvel exécutif ce
quinquennat pour ce quinquennat qui qui
qui qui fait du surplace qui a
l'impression qu'on est dans le
prolongement du premier quinquennat et
que le deuxième quinquennat va jamais
commencé il ya quand même une campagne
législative
donc on attend de ce gouvernement est ce
qu'il affiche des priorités les grandes
priorités de politique publique est ce
qu'il ya un équilibre politique on va
pouvoir essayer de commenter en voyant
les crimes entre des personnalités
venant de la gauche ou venant de la
droite sk les nouvelles personnalités ce
que ces nouvelles personnalités ont un
impact possible sur l'opinion alors les
allées regardez les premières images de
l'elysée paie moi si c'est pour nous
normalement troupes et moi il faut
expliquer a oui c'est surtout pas rater
l'entrée en lice de 2 alexis colère par
ce conseil n'est pas très fan de cet
exercice à l'exercice oui un ce qui
paraît il aime pas beaucoup il est
scruté on regarde ce qu'il fait alors on
essaye de se projeter on a des premières
pistes ce qu'ont appris dans la journée
et qui est quasiment certain on verra
attendons quasiment certain à 99% olivia
grégoire porte-parole du gouvernement
qui olivier grégoire c'est assez
intéressant le porte parole du
gouvernement parce qu'il n'a pas
forcément de portefeuille surtout depuis
quelques temps sous vaincrons il n'y a
pas de portefeuille pour gabriel attal
par exemple est très exposé c'est un
poste nous vois un je dit oui c'est un
battant on voit ces c'est extrêmement
risqué
livia grégoire c'est une femme de gauche
qui a été proche de manuel phase donc il
représente cette sensibilité
laïcité républicaine à gauche en terme
d'autorité aussi elle s'est distinguée
par des positions qui n'ont rien au
rejet licques et femmes de gauche c'est
important parce que dans l'été
quinconces et monseigneur je précise de
raffarin
quand il était premier ministre et de
xavier bertrand quand il était à la
santé donc voilà elle était conseillère
oui c'est pas de vous forcément ça donne
pas forcément une tendance politique
mais quand même elle peut jouer sur les
deux tableaux ça marche a été
conseillère technique à cet effet
annoncé hier quand vous épluchez les cv
vous tomber sur ce genre sur ce genre de
carrière mais c'est vrai que en tout cas
ne pouvait pas être mélenchonistes par
exemple non non non ça c'est sûr mais
c'est vous avez raison c'est un poste
important un porte-parole a et surtout
gabriela talent a fait quoi là bien
qu'on pense de la politique du
gouvernement précédent a quand même
marqué nous on se passe alors que sa
prédécesseur avait pas forcément marquer
toujours positivement c'est un poste
extrêmement difficile parce qu'il faut
que vous sortiez des éléments techniques
que vous donne les conseillers
techniques pour donner un peu de sens
politique à l'action du gouvernement et
de ce point de vue là c'est une des
députés quand même de la majorité
sortante cas quand même un peu émerger
car ici à prendre mission dans la
majorité sortante aux députés le rm sans
leur faire injure
il n'avait pas toujours des
personnalités qui ont réussi à percer
notamment médiatiquement donc olivier
grégoire a quand même réussi ça
donc c'est peut-être une des rares
parlementaires sortante qui va entrer et
puis attention elle était secrétaire
d'état quand même à l'économie et à
l'économie solidaire vous serez une
raison c'est quand même 43 ans je
corrige alors ses propos elle et on l'a
vu dans l'est dans les médias
lorsqu'elles étaient enceintes l'année
dernière et que olivier ferrand lui a
fait lui même le vaccin c'était pour
promouvoir le vaccin pour les pour les
femmes enceintes deuxième nom qui est
sorti un peu de nulle part aujourd'hui
on verra on voyait ces images si vous
nous rejoignez et puis vous pouvez
réagir sur lefigaro.fr sur youtube sur
twitch je prends vos questions je les
transmets à nos deux experts deuxième
nom donc catherine colonna catherine
colonna qui pourrait arriver aux
affaires étrangères qui est catherine
colonna alors ça c'est une chiraquienne
pur sucre qui est deux formations
diplomate ce qui justifie en tout cas
ses attributions ministérielles
si elle confirme un restons prudents on
n'est jamais à l'abri d'un changement
après d'avoir de pompage autre fausse
information cc c'est une énarque elle a
une caractéristique on parlait de des
difficultés du poste de porte parole
elle a le record de longévité à ce poste
elle l'a fait neuf ans de 1995 de plus
un porte parole du président de la
république y en a plus y en a
normalement non il est
confondue avec d'autres l'autre fonction
mais en tout cas si c'est une belle
preuve de solidité parce que resté neuf
ans dont quelque 95 2002 bien sûr sous
jacques chirac à ce poste très exposé
ça veut dire qu'on en est on est très
costaud alors allah était portant les
pieds elle a été ministre et les
affaires européennes
exactement ministre délégué aux affaires
européennes et puis elle a été aussi
deux fois ambassadrice ambassadrice de
france elle est actuellement
ambassadrice de france au royaume uni
elle est ambassadrice de france en
italie et alors je savoure en danger à
grande échelle a nommé élevée à la
dignité d'ambassadrice de france et
seulement trois femmes qui sont dans
cette situation c'était une décision du
conseil de ministres ans en 2020 c'est
un nom qui sort un peu du chapeau on est
avec une techno l'un c'est une grande
professionnelle de la diplomatie vous
venez de de retracer sa carrière est
tout à fait remarquable donc qu'elles
apparaissent un poste qui est toujours
un petit peu ingrat le poste de faire
indemniser affaires étrangères parce que
c'est le président de la république quel
chef de la diplomatie donc il faut être
proximité très forte avec les présidents
à république sans quoi le miz affaires
étrangères est un peu en suspension dans
l'air plus ou moins libre et donc
catherine kaunas est une grande
professionnelle
c'est une technicienne c'est le summum
de la haute fonction publique on peut
dire c'est pas une politique même si
elle a beaucoup travaillé avec avec
jacques chirac x et une chiraquienne
donc c'est un c'est une forte
personnalité très professionnel alors là
ce sera pareil presque taillée pour lui
la fonction de ministre à faire ça tout
de suite dans le bain vous le dit
d'habitude est forcément un temps
d'adaptation là on rappelle le contexte
guerre en ukraine entendu dit d'une part
guerre en ukraine mais ça
vous avez raison de souligner et matous
président de la république en cas de
conflit est en première ligne et en plus
la façon dont emmanuel macron gère
la guerre en ukraine de france avec ce
comptage qui l'entretient d'une part
avec vladimir poutine et d'autres pas
avec avec des élèves ce qui fait que
c'est pas sur ce terrain là qu'elle
prendra les décisions ou quel sera le
plus en vue en revanche c'est un dossier
très difficile
sur lequel elle va débarquer et qu'elle
va devoir résoudre en fait lll elle
débarque dans un seul débat dans un
climat de révolte puisque la suppression
et du corps diplomatique
la syrie a annoncé que corps
diplomatique auquel elle appartient donc
c'est une des leurs et c'est peut-être
pour ça aussi a voulu courir un
croisement d'arrondir les angles exact
pour rassurer les gains de la maison qui
va être chargé un mois que le président
abandonne cette idée de réforme qui va
être chargé de cette mise au pas tout ce
qui faisait la spécificité qui portent
ni plus salée raison c'est extrêmement
important ça fait beaucoup de bruit dans
dont le corps diplomatique et ou de la
salle dans la haute fonction publique et
est donc catherine colonna de ce point
de vue là qu'on est un produit le pur
produit est un produit émérite
peu rassuré peut-être un ensemble de
hauts fonctionnaires qui peuvent être
inquiets par l'évolution peuvent avoir
été inquiété par l'évolution de la de
l'hérault de fonction publique donc ça
c'est très important je salue tous ceux
qui nous rejoignent latence sur
lefigaro.fr je vois qui nous rejoint 4
jacquier la magali également marqué un
qui me dit quel suspense oui oui du
suspense on revient on va rester
maintenant avec ces images en direct
depuis l'elysée parce qu alexis colère
devrait apparaître d'une minute à
l'autre on nous a dit 16h15 conséquent
en macro nice et pas forcément
toujours gage de jager un peu dans lé
giro on est d'accord alors je précise
aussi qu'un nom remonte remonte pas
vraiment puisqu'il est déjà au
gouvernement mais qu'il devrait y rester
un poste un peu supérieure puisqu'il est
actuellement secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes clément bonn
devrait devenir ministre des affaires
européennes voilà dans la dans la lignée
de ce qu'on vient de dire à propos de
catherine colonna deux personnalités
très fortes qui devrait rester bruno le
maire et gérald darmanin assassin
philippe ce sont les cadres a finalement
de wheelman c'est très important parce
que ça peut donner une coloration à ce
gouvernement à la fois politique mais
aussi en termes de continuité espère que
s'il se confirme que bruno le maire
reste à l'économie et que j'ai un gamin
darmanin reste à l'intérieur sont deux
postes politiques très exposé
médiatiquement notamment le ministre
l'intérieur
et donc ça donnera un parfum de
continuité à ce gouvernement puisque à
ce stade on va peut-être avoir des
surprises c'est tout l'intérêt de suivre
la la composition on n'a pas de très
fortes personnalités
marquées à gauche ou à droite avec une
très forte notoriété un très fort en
enseignements politiques qui ont l'air
je reste prudent ils ont l'air d'entrer
dans ce gouvernement peut-être damien
abad
on le verra mais en tout cas ça donne à
ce gouvernement un air de continuité qui
était déjà un peu
sensible avec la nomination d'elisabeth
baume qui était ministre sortante donc
ça s'adonne à ce gouvernement un côté on
prend les mêmes et on refait pas tout à
fait la même chose mais on est dans la
même dans la dans la continuité de
l'action menée à la fin du premier
quinquennat je dis toujours donne la
parole sur c'est sur ces deux cadres je
demande à ryadh becker qui en régie avec
nous et qui orchestrent orchestre cette
émission qu'on reste maintenant en
direct sur ces images à l'elysée parce
qu'on attend d'un instant à l'autre le
secrétaire général qui doit annoncer la
liste de ce gouvernement bruno le maire
gérald darmanin il peut plus s'en passer
manuel maquereau en tout cas à ses yeux
ils n'ont pas démérité
ils ont été
là et l'autre en première ligne
absolument tout le temps gérald harlin a
en plus eu des épreuves personnelles
ses démêlés avec la justice pour une
affaire de moeurs la justice qui a
finalement dit qu'il était absolument
innocent ça ça ça ça a beaucoup secoué
des mets aux féministes réclament
réclamé sa démission au cours de
manifestations régulières donc ça veut
dire que vraiment c'est de la part des
bagnes mâcon la reconnaissance de la
solidité et du travail accompli même
chose pour bruno le maire qui vit n'a eu
aucun délai avec avec la justice qui
disait avant
la présidentielle qui se voyait bien
rester à son poste
ayant compris d'ailleurs qu' il avait
fort peu de chances d'être nommé à
matignon oui mais oui parce que en fait
ce sont des cadres mais emmanuel macron
ne voulait pas des personnalités
politiques trop forte qui pourrait avoir
une ambition c'est de la honte c'est ils
ont des ambitions présidentielles à
terme à terme mais seulement
dans l'état actuel de ce qu'on suppose
sur ce gouvernement c'est quand même
la continuité qui prévaut avec le
maintien de
le maire
darmanin c'est extrêmement important on
sait en revanche on espère ne pas être
démentie dans deux minutes que un autre
poids lourd jean michel blanquer air
devrait quitter l'éducation oui aussi
porte rêvait de matignon et pas
seulement en se rasant mais il a arrêté
de se rallier l'arrivée
mais c'est quand même un d un des
piliers qui parle il ya une grande
inconnue en tout cas moi je n'ai pas eu
d'informations fiables à ce stade c'est
quid d'olivier ferrand alors vraie
incertitude sur le ministère de la santé
vous avez là un ministère primordial
primordial quoi qu'il arrive
primordial pendant la crise sanitaire
est primordial parce qu'il ya une crise
de la santé en général et bicoll
hospitalière en particulier qui est en
train d'éclater en ce moment donc
vraiment les auges ans voilà avec une
donation supplice simplement pas
simplement une crise généralisée avec
des problèmes de règles de recrutement
énorme d énormes avec une spécificité
qui est le découpage ministériel et rs
que le ou la futur ministre de la santé
aura aussi des affaires sociales alors
oui parce que on est ce que c'est le
ministère du travail un titre et
ministère de la santé et des solidarités
et il se dit qu olivier ferrand ne
serait que santé lui qui est médecin et
on s'est un peu mieux déclare le volet
solidarité c'est un vieux débat du
gouvernementale parce que le ministre de
la santé est en fait un secteur énorme
et qui est lourd à gérer on de même en
dehors des pandémies a fortiori pendant
les pandémies
et que les affaires sociales dans les
affaires sociales et de la solidarité
il y a un petit sujet qui s'appelle les
retraites ah oui sur lequel le président
réélu a fait de petites annonces avant
et donc le savoir quel est le ministre
le ou la ministre qui va être chef de
projet sur la réforme des retraites qui
a été annoncé est annoncée même si on ne
connaît
toutes les dimensions c'est tellement
qu'on puisse dire le flou sortir de
l'ambiguïté serait peut-être dangereux à
ce stade
mais de savoir quel est le ou la
ministre qui sera en charge de suivre de
piloter ce projet quand même extrêmement
important sur le plan politique donc ça
peut être le ministre ou la ministre de
la santé et de la solidarité
ça peut être aussi le ministre du
travail puisque le sujet retraite un
petit rapport avec le travail donc ça
c'est un poste à temps partagé la route
aussi que l'avait été mis en place un
ministère des retraites souvenez-vous
avec laurent pietra chef qui avait pris
ce poste là donc cette possibilité est
ouverte également j cole qui nous dit
sur youtube bonjour a tous hâte de voir
le casting oui on attend d'un instant à
l'autre avec 6 colère ksl le niveau
d'anglais de catherine colonna alors on
imagine très bon puisqu'elle est
actuellement
ambassadrice française de la france au
royaume uni et par très bon voilà ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle si elles
doivent parler notamment avec les
différents dirigeants étrangers on parle
de ceux qui s'en vont on a des noms on
est sûr qu'ils ne seront plus là dans la
bible au caire social important parce
que la relation des professeurs
avec jean michel becker était devenu
totalement détestable à tort ou à raison
je promets on prononce pas sur le fond
mais les relations entre bancaire et son
administration et ses fonctionnaires
était devenu parfaitement détestable et
c'est un enjeu là aussi politique non
négligeable de savoir qui sera le futur
ministre de l'éducation nationale parce
que c'est un secteur qui a comme un goût
protester contre la politique de jean
michel blanc coeur dont le vote a été
plus peut-être plus orienté vers jean
luc mélenchon aux présidentielles du
fait notamment de ce mécontentement à
l'égard de jean michel blanquer et donc
la dimension politique du personnage qui
sera nommé tout en jaune après tout le
monde veut semer nesta alors qu'il est
difficile en a entendu le nom de jean
castex bon évidemment ce ne sera pas lui
on entend des mre à la gabriela talent
julien de normandie bruno le maire
marlène schiappa et leur sens qu'ils le
voulaient tous ce ministère de
l'éducation nationale alors c'est le
plus gros budget on le sait c'est
difficile je dit d'être ministre de
l'éducation nationale enfin difficile il
faut savoir prendre des coups
on va faire autre chose non
effectivement succès c'est un ministère
où il ya beaucoup de coups à prendre et
jean michel blanquer en sait quelque
chose lui il est plutôt proche de la
droite on sait qu'ils vont vraiment
c'est un pur produit
du système éducation nationale il avait
suscité énormément d'espoir notamment
dans l'électorat de droite est dans
notre lectorat au moment de sa
nomination parce qu'il disait des choses
qu'on rêvait d'entendre sur le retour
aux apprentissages fondamentaux
lire écrire compter et
réintroduire la notion de respect dans
les classes il était également
très engagée sur le front de la laïcité
parce que je rappelle que c'est lui qui
avait dit que le voile islamique n'était
pas souhaitable dans la société
française la croyez contre certaines
dérives syndical je pense à sud
éducation saine samedi notamment quand
il avait imaginé de faire leur atelier
en on mixité sur deux genres
et de race mais peut-être que je me
trompe
en tout cas donc discuter c'était
lorthiois un cadre
organisé vous savez des colloques
sarr bonne il me semble parler où il
était très engagé sur cette question
très engagé ça n'a pas suffi à
convaincre emmanuel macron pour le
garder non parce que par ailleurs quand
vous disiez
relations détestables or que je vous
coupe en écoute alexis colère évidemment
qui annonce le gouvernement écologique
et énergétique
le président de la république a nommé
monsieur bruno le maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
monsieur gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur
madame catherine colonna
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères
monsieur eric dupond-moretti
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
madame amélie de montchanin
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur pape ndiaye
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
monsieur sébastien lecornu
ministre des armées
madame brigitte bourguignon
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
monsieur olivier du soft
ministre du travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
monsieur damien abad
ministre des solidarités de l'autonomie
et des personnes handicapées
madame sylvie retailleau
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
monsieur marc fesneau
ministre de l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire
messieurs stanislas guérini
ministre de la transformation et de la
fonction publique
manamia elle brown pie v
ministre d outre-mer
madame rima abdel malak
ministre de la culture
madame agnès pannier une hache et
ministre de la transition énergétique
madame amélie oudéa castéra
ministre des sports et des jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
sont nommés ministres délégués
auprès de la première ministre
monsieur olivier véran
chargé des relations avec le parlement
et de la vie démocratique
madame isabelle rom
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes de la diversité et de
l'égalité des chances
auprès du ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique
lesieu gabriel attal chargé des comptes
publics
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur et de
la ministre de la transition écologique
de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur christophe béchu chargé des
collectivités territoriales
auprès de la ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères monsieur franck
riester
chargé du commerce extérieur et de
l'attractivité
monsieur clément bonne chargé de
l'europe
sont nommé secrétaire d'état
auprès de la première ministre
madame olivia grégoire
porte-parole du gouvernement
madan justine bénin
chargé de la mer
madame charlotte caubel
chargée de l'enfance
auprès de la ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères madame crise ou là à
carreaux pulu chargé du développement
de la francophonie et des partenariats
internationaux
le président de la république réunira le
conseil des ministres avec l'ensemble
des membres du gouvernement
lundi 23 mai à 10 heures
je vous remercie
là bas dit me dupond moretti qui reste
elle a juste et voilà vous avez entendu
philippe d'hiver on est en direct mais
c'est vrai c'est ça la première
information ça y est on a le
gouvernement je le ressens que c'est un
gouvernement resserré on n'a pas le
temps de compter mais je crois que par
rapport à tout ce que à tout ce que j'ai
noté un jld avait mimé des des petites
cases sur mes feuilles pour remplir
petit à petit j'ai beaucoup de vide pour
l'instant oui la grande information eric
dupond-moretti qu'on croyait sortant
reste ministre de la justice c'est
l'information il me semble de cette
annonce d'alexis colère et c'est une
information vraiment surprenante enfin
mes yeux dans la mesure où on en avait
pas parlé auparavant mais lui même était
en grand conflit c'est un euphémisme
avec le corps des magistrats est donc
plus en délicatesse avec la justice et
accessoirement délicatesse avec la
justice puisque mise en examen est donc
ça c'est une vraie surprise qui renforce
quand même l'impression de continuité
dont on parlait tout à l'heure puisque
dans non seulement il ya des ministres
qui reste en passe du port maritime et
c'est le cas de darmanin c'est le cas
évidemment de l'omert
mais il ya aussi des ministres du
gouvernement sortant qui changent de
fonction donc à un turnover mais à
travers au sein d'une équipe où les
nouveaux entrants ne sont pas si
nombreuses c'est vrai qu'il y là je me
souviens quatre ou trois mois on
n'entendait que emmanuel macron ne
voulait garder que quatre ou cinq
minutes c'est pas du tout le cas y en a
beaucoup qui restent certains restent à
leur poste beaucoup changent de poste
c'est ça oui oui absolument
sur quoi vous voulez réagir qu'est-ce
qui vous parle pour tout vous dire a pas
évident avant la grosse surprise du
maintien d'eric dupond-moretti
ce qui m'étonne beaucoup c'est
l'identité du nouveau ministre de
l'éducation
j'avais parié
de l'engagement de jean michel bancaire
pour la laïcité avec pape ndiaye on est
complètement hors jeu rien dans l'autre
l'autre champ
il s'est notamment illustré par un
rapport sur la diversité à l'opéra
alors dites-nous c'est papa nalla jeu
alors que tout vous dire je le jeu le
découvrons là jour sa part
setha d'historia ses sculptures réputé
spécialiste des minorités
qui a qui a passé une partie des
carrières ou aux états unis revoilà
historien spécialiste de l'histoire
sociale n'a pas été complètement
imprégné
de des colonialistes qui pratique ah oui
pardon qui complètement
qui pratiquent la sienne l'assignation à
résidence identitaire dans le rapport
sur l'opéra dont je vous parlais rapport
sur la diversité qui dans la conclusion
était qu'il en avait pas il comptait les
les personnes en situation de non
blanchi t et c'était écrit non
blanchitude dans le rapport et les
autres alors que s'accélérer tonnes
entre services chargement pas du tout de
continuité entre jean michel blanquer a
guidé ma peine de les vans masse totale
une volte-face total alors
je ne connais pas toutes les oeuvres
noeud pap ndiaye mais en tout cas celle
que je connais montre un changement
absolument radicales et un changement
pour moi dans le mauvais sens d'accord
et vous philippe ça vous surprend c'est
une surprise parce que d'avancer deux
vraies personnalités du monde
intellectuel et de la société civile
comme on disait jadis donc il n'est pas
du tout du sérail politique même si
comme le disait j il a eu des prises de
position et des engagements et donc
c'est une vraie surprise puisque il ne
semble pas qu'on si vous me permettez
l'expression famille là qu'on l'avait vu
venir à ce poste et donc c'est une des
vraies surprises de nouvel entrant dans
ce gouvernement c'est un spécialiste de
la condition noire aux etats-unis qui a
beaucoup écrit sur la situation
française il faudra vérifier s'ils ont
tant que ministre mais en tant que
ministre de l'éducation nationale
quelle sera la tonalité de son discours
puisqu'il arrive que quand on passe
d'une position d'intellectuels et de et
d'analystes et quand on rentre dans un
gouvernement et qu'on s'engage dans la
vie politique il est petit il arrive que
les positions soient pas exactement les
mêmes et qu'il me semble qui devra tenir
compte du contexte politique dans lequel
il est la deuxième surprise qui n'en
attendez je précise avant que vous
partez sur votre deuxième surprise pour
expliquer aux gens qui nous rejoignent
pap ndiaye a donc été nommé ministre de
l'éducation nationale il a 56 ans il est
actuellement le directeur général du
palais de la porte dorée et dirige le
musée de l'histoire de l'immigration
c'est un historien spécialiste des
minorités voilà c'est votre deuxième
surprise allons-y alors s'établir à bab
parce qu'elle sait pas une surprise en
soi qui voulait quand même pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent que je fasse un petit
point là vous voyez défiler ces noms en
bas vous allez les voir défiler les
nouveaux ministres mais comme ça ceux
qui nous rejoignent peuvent avoir une
idée en tout cas des ministères
importants ministère de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin ministère des armées
sébastien lecornu ministère des affaires
étrangères catherine colonna
planification territoriale c'est amélie
de montchalin et planification
énergétique c'est à un espagnol n'achète
donc ça c'est un duo pour l'écologie ces
deux femmes qui seront aux côtés
d'elisabeth bornes bruno le maire reste
ministre de l'économie et des finances
au premier rang au premier rang
absolument ça c'est très important
l'ordre protocolaire du gouvernent juste
devant gérald darmanin cessa l'ordre
bruno le maire gérald darmanin eric
dupond-moretti reste ministre de la
justice pap ndiaye donc à l'éducation et
puis je descends brigitte bourguignon
ministre de la santé marc fesneau à
l'agriculture olivier dussopt pts
travail porte parole olivia grégoire et
donc vous voulez me parler des
solidarités damien abad qui hier encore
était député lr patron dlr à l'assemblée
voilà donc c'est là la lite
laprise politique si on peut dire le
terme de prix c'est pas très élégant
pour une personne mais c'est là le le
grand élu des républicains qui entrent
au gouvernement un de plus et qui
entrent sur une fonction dont on parlait
tout à l'heure juste avant la nomination
qui est la fonction ministère des
solidarités puisque emmanuel macron
elisabeth bornes ont pris la décision de
scinder le ministère de la santé et des
affaires sociales pour en faire un
ministère de la santé et à ministère des
solidarités qui revient donc à deux bien
et j'en profite pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent au 6e jeu luis oliveira en
reste au gouvernement mais ce pour le
ministre délégué aux relations avec le
parlement voilà comme ça c'est dit le
ministre de la santé alors de chose
quand même damien abad oui on vous a
coupé qui n'est pas juste pour finir
d'une phrase a priori dans ce que je lis
de la composition du gouvernement
il sera donc le ch il saurait donc on va
mettre du conditionnel le chef de projet
sur une éventuelle réforme des retraites
ce qui me semble politiquement tout à
fait significatif puisque c'est un
ministre qui vient des républicains sur
un sujet qui est sensible pour
l'électorat de droite et notamment
l'électorat de droite âgé qui est très
favorable à une réforme des retraites et
qui a rejoint emmanuel macron sur pas
mal de deux critères mais notamment
aussi sur la perspective de cette
réforme avec la retraite à 65 ans et
donc on ne sait pas encore quelle sera
la nature de cette réforme mais en tout
cas c'est lui qui en sera
potentiellement chargé sur un doublé
doulcier sociaux les plus sensibles
de la rentrée prochaine si cette réforme
est lancé à la rentrée prochaine donc
politiquement ça semble pas très
important on nous pose un grand élu des
républicains à une éventuelle
contestation sociale sur la réforme des
retraites juste avant deux avant de vous
lancer judith serais pour dominique
stahl sur youtube qui me demande qui est
ministre de la santé c'est brigitte
bourguignon qui prend donc ce poste
allez-y président bourguignon fans de
gauche oui d'amis ahamadi cie s'est
illustré
en refusant jusqu'au dernier moment de
lâcher la proie pour l'ombre parce que
christian jacob a dû taper du poing sur
la table pour qu'il abandonne ses
fonctions à la tête
du groupe l'est républicain à
l'assemblée dans sa carrière elle avait
il avait été repéré par hervé morin qui
était patron des centristes avaient
bravé à sebral vécu déjà ce que lui
considéré comme une trahison quand
damien abad était parti pour les
républicains là il s'éloigne encore un
peu plus après avoir dit pis que pendre
de la gestion des manuels mathon maison
du bessat cévennes sarthe et comme
edouard philippe souvenez-vous qu'il
était même le premier ministre alors
qu'il avait fait la campagne à droite
pendant la présidentielle
je ne sais pas si vous avez remarqué
mais dans l'intitulé des ministères
revient à plusieurs reprises le mot
souveraineté oui tout à fait et c'est
tout à fait nouveau vous avez le maire
et que les finances chargé de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
de la france vous avez marc fesneau à
l'agriculture chargé de la souveraineté
alimentaire la france décrit sont passés
par là d'une part et d'autre part la
montée
de la sensibilité chevénementiste
souverainiste précisément
anti-européenne ou en tout cas pour une
autre europe dans le pays les résultats
il veut la présidentielle sont pris en
compte la qualification de la une le pen
au deuxième tour et le et le très bon
score de jean luc mélenchon et la crise
sanitaire
est également passé par là on sent que
les débats qui nous ont agité sur
l'extrême dépendance de la france
à l'asie notamment et la chine en
particulier
des bas qui ont rebondit
actuellement puisque le pouvoir d'achat
est gravement affectés par
des pénuries de produits qui précisément
qui viennent de chine donc la
souveraineté est au coeur du débat
politique elle l'est depuis que vive
elle est aujourd'hui à propos du pouvoir
d'achat et nos difficultés économiques
et de l'inflation évidemment et ça c'est
un signal très clair
envoyé par emmanuel macron qui donc
ajoute un mot à son vocabulaire alors
c'est pas tout à fait nouveau puisque
moment des européennes déjà il parler de
souveraineté européenne ce nouveau que
ça apparaisse dans l'intitulé de mystère
on compterait oui alors s'il vous plaît
fils parce que des gens nous rejoignent
beaucoup de monde nous nous rejoint sur
youtube sur lefigaro.fr sur twitch vrai
qu'on leur fasse un petit point complet
quand même des destinataires et puis on
on ira sur ce qui vous surprend alors
dans l'ordre vous l'avez dit le premier
ministre à avoir été nommée c'est bruno
le maire ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté numérique
c'est bien ça gérald darmanin reste
ministre de l'intérieur aux armées se
blinder industrialisés voilà pour être
très précis sébastien lecornu et aux
armées lui qui est un des proches il
était aux outremers pourtant c'est une
récompense et c'est presque étonnant on
voit aussi en parler parce que les
outre-mer ont voté massivement pour
marine le pen donc ne sont pas forcément
très content pour jean luc mélenchon
d'abord puis pour marine le pen au
second tour pas forcément très content
de la politique menée par par emmanuel
macron et ses équipes et pourtant on
récompense sébastien lecornu aux
affaires étrangères la nouvelle on va
beaucoup en parlent et j'imagine
catherine colonna la planification
territoriale ce amélie de montchalin la
planification énergétique c'est agnès
pannier rue nager ça c'est pour le duo
du pôle écolo un finalement la grande
priorité du quinquennat je vous laisse
finir la wii je finis par ce que ce nom
qui nous surprend tous eric
dupond-moretti reste donc ministre de la
justice et puis je note grosse surprise
c'est ça ou 130 sur youtube qui nous dit
pape ndiaye grosse surprise on va
reparler c'est le premier nom vous
voulez soulever tout à l'heure à les ai
je dit non juste une remarque sur amélie
de montchalin quitte une des découvertes
je trouve du quinquennat qui s'est
achevée quelques unes une femme jeune
femme dont les origines politiques sont
plutôt de droite j'ai playlist je compte
sur le juppéiste oui alors ça c'est un
moderne pacifique at il de droite en
2010 ans elle ne vient pas à gauche
qu'est ce qui est surtout très important
c'est que c'est pas une figure de
l'écologie or elle sera chargée d'
assumer la transition et là on sent
qu'ils viennent de la pénurie ne s'est
pas vraiment non plus au nord sur le
pool énergétique si peut-être un peu
différent on va parler du nucléaire rome
et c'est logique ça sera quand même
plutôt ameline montchanin et ça c'est à
mon avis emmanuel macron qui ayant
chermain pays d'avoir choisi une figure
symbolique comme nicolas hulot
à la transition écologique on a parlé de
monsieur qu'enfin notamment voilà ça
aurait été une figure
une source d'inquiétude m'en assurer
parce que quand vous prenez quelqu'un
issu de la mouvance des militants écolos
vous êtes sûr ça va se finir comme
nicolas hulot
finalement j'ai bien réfléchi
aujourd'hui barbara pour puis ça s'est
bien passé ceux ci qu'est ce qu'elle a
fait oui c'est vrai que d une loi oui
c'est vrai qu'elle est tombée à des
périodes un peu partie de meilleur jeu
posé la note est donc c'est quelqu'un de
techniquement extrêmement compétents
idéologiquement pas marqué écolo qui va
prendre en charge la transition
écologique et c'est un virage dans
l'appréhension de ces problèmes c'est
vrai et ça veut peut-être d'autant plus
dire qu'elle dise à melbourne premier
mini première ministre excusez-moi
va être la vraie patronne de la
politique écologique de la france c'est
à dire que de ce point de vue là ce si
je comprends la logique de la
composition de ce gouvernement
de très fortes technicienne des
personnalités très compétente qui
accompagne elisabeth borne donc ça veut
dire que politiquement c'est elisabeth
bornes qui va apporter beaucoup la
politique écologique moi j'avais juste
une petite surprise dans les 5 ordi on
ne parle pas des sortants marlène
schiappa n'est plus ministre oui alors
qu'elle était très apprécié notamment de
brigitte macron qui poussait pour
qu'elle reste et marlène schiappa aurait
énervé à force c'est ce qu'il se dit
enfin possible la double personnalité
alors des sortants mais on va quand même
faire la liste de ceux qui restent
gabriella talent on en parlait il a
plutôt convaincu dans son rôle de porte
parole il est au budget la salle c'est
un rôle beaucoup plus habré beaucoup
plus ingrat oui oui beaucoup moins
exposé mais très technique où il faut
discuter beaucoup avec l'assemblée
nationale le sénat et ses olives et
veyran lui aussi il reste aux relations
avec le parlement commerce extérieur
franck riester un autre qui je crois que
j ai d'ailleurs c'est comme ça c'est
assez assez amusant quand même relations
avec le parlement pour olivier veyrat
parce qu'on se souvienne pendant la
crise sanitaire il avait piqué des
colères homériques où il était allé
jusqu'à dire sortez si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord aux députés alors que lui était
ministre et que les députés étaient chez
eux à l'assemblée nationale en plein
hémicycle que tout simplement parce
qu'il contestait certains aspects
relatifs à son prof de plus belle comme
assise et +22 d'empathie avec la
fonction parlementaire je pense et il
passe d'un poste hyper exposé un poste
qui médiatiquement les très peu il
s'impose politiquement important vers la
sueur et que parlement parce que vous
êtes en relation constante avec la
majorité les groupes à l'assemblée donc
vous avec le président du groupe du
futur groupe majoritaire si emmanuel
macron obtient bien une majorité mais
partie des personnages qui organise le
travail du parlement en lien avec le
travail gouvernemental mais c'est un
poste qui médiatiquement est beaucoup
moins marc fesneau qu'est le ministre
sortant et que tu un type tout à fait
apprécier tout à fait oui alors bonne
élève qui se disait le bon élève des
gouvernements récompensé avec la nsa de
l'agriculture et 1 passe le plus exposé
parce que dans le contexte que nous
connaissons avec les difficultés liées à
la crise une chrétienne et les
conséquences alimentaires sur le
la situation dans ce trouble dans
laquelle se trouve l'agriculture
française c'est un poste qui peut être
pour lui beaucoup plus
exposées avec potentiellement des crises
sociales ou économiques liées à
l'agriculture sur lesquelles ils
seraient obligés d'intervenir c'est un
monde qu'il connaît extrêmement bien
extrêmement bien qu'il a beaucoup
travaillée
alors son petit handicap aussi c'est que
son prédécesseur a été extrêmement
apprécié julien 2 en 3d d'ailleurs parlé
aux agriculteurs s'étaient amini ce
formidable jamais au canada lancé une
autre et hop les pressions julien
d'amendis approche des manuels macron
qui n'est pas dans dans ce gouvernement
je vous laisse continuer sur marc
fesneau c'est aussi un des rares
ministres modem sauf erreur de ma part
c'était lui qui au gouvernement
représentaient le modem et qu'ils
étaient dans les discussions des
négociations pour les investitures
notamment au gesù confirmé
aux manettes du parti de françois bayrou
après longtemps donc c'est lui on peut
le représentant de françois bayroux au
sein du gouvernement et je ne vois pas
d'autre dans le précédent au quinquennat
dire et jacqueline gourault
il y avait d'autres ministres si vous
n'arrêtez pas d'ici là soit valero qui
n'est pas resté longtemps également
c'est aussi ça le problème pour le pour
le modèle je vous coupe à un instant
parce que je voudrais quand même parler
si vous voulez bien avec
avec judith d'olivia grégoire
porte-parole du gouvernement elle elle
va être très exposé on va la voir c'est
la première qu'on va voir lundi à la
sortie du premier conseil des ministres
oui elle à profit de gauche elle était
proche de manuel valls
on sait que manuel valls a obtenu une
investiture dans une
dans la serre cure
circonscription pardon des français de
l'étranger
portugal ou d'organes kako voilà
bon c'est un signe de plus que
manuel valls et ce qu'il représente sont
vraiment rentrer en grâce
aux yeux des bannis maintenant auprès
d'emmanuel macro est ce que ça satisfera
l'électorat de gauche je ne suis pas sûr
mais je ne suis pas sûr non plus que ce
soit fait pour non parce que quand on
regarde les clips plus générale du
gouvernement j'étais andres temps de
réfléchir
ce qui dénigre slim ainsi que les droits
de vote oui les mises à hormis la
première ministre elisabeth bornes qui
vient de la gauche effectivement aux
farc depuis cinq ans ministre alors
qu'elles sont dites moi les cinq plus
grands ministères les plus visibles
intérieur intérieur et économie donc
deux hommes de droite un deux hommes de
droite alors parce que le ministère des
solidarités de damien abad a vocation à
devenir très visible si c'est bien lui
qui n'a de la mairie forme de retraite
on vient avec matignon la justice un
homme mais plutôt de gauche toute la
gauche
je vois un monsieur oui oui faut
discuter enfin après tout dépend ce
qu'on définition qu'on donne de la
gauche
et dont s'approcheront aller
l'association est clairement s'avère
moins à gauche un homme qui vient de la
gauche universitaire
pour pas dire de la gauche diversiterre
et donc effectivement le équilibres
politiques on a le sentiment que sur les
fonctions les plus
régaliens à droite lors éolien est à
droite et même les parties du social
avec damien abad sur les retraites
l'économie et à doha l'économie est à
droite l'éducation est à gauche et
peut-être un peu le ministère de la
justice pour mais cette nomination
d'eric dupond-moretti quand même extra
maintien on n'y revient pas je suis un
peu désolé mais j'avais totalement
raison on a balayé si vous nous
rejoignez l'ensemble des ministères vous
refera un petit point que vous voyez
cette liste qui défile on va vous pouvez
aussi retrouver sur le figaro.fr la
liste complète de tous les ministres
mais il ya ce nom et tout de suite
philippe vous m'avez dit quand on a
représenté mais quelle surprise et on a
tous fait tous les trois sentais un peu
provocation pardon à l'égard du corps
des magistrats cirque un ministre de la
justice qui a été en conflit qui mise en
examen comme l'appelait et judith qui
est qu'il n'a pas vraiment convaincu pas
dont 2 je trouve pas qui par rapport aux
sujets d'insécurité de critiques de la
justice il était complètement planté qui
électoralement ses couilles parce qu'en
fait aux régionales ou deux parties
minable où département
chasse et le rassemblement national de
ses terres et bientôt lui qui a été
tout ça fait quand même un bilan de
ministre qui était pas tout à fait
évident on sait d'ailleurs que les
personnalités qui viennent de la société
civile leur acclimatation dans l'univers
politique et gouvernementale n'est pas
toujours évident et il est reconduit ce
un petit côté provocation et fait du
prince quand même de la part d' emmanuel
macron alors on avait l'impression aussi
qu'il était obligé auprès de lui parce
que j'imagine qu'ils auraient dû point
mérite il eut fait une sorte de cadeau
en donnant son nom il ya deux ans hélas
le lâcher en jeu je me mets dans la tête
d'emmanuel macron lâché eric dupond
moretti en pleine nature avec une mise
en examen sans circonscription pour eux
devenir avocat ce qui paraît difficile
avant ce qui peut paraître difficile
c'est peut-être un cadeau qu'il fait
cette fois eric dupond-moretti je dit je
suis peut-être cynique mais j'ai du mal
à croire que les impératifs humain de
préval sur 1 150 ont cru quand on crée
un gouvernement il est tellement
important politiquement d'avoir un
minimum de confiance on a remarqué déjà
qu emmanuel macron n'avait pas d'état de
grâce que seule une courte très courte
majorité de français selon les divers
sondages qui ont été réalisés
approuvent ils font confiance la
nomination d'élise à genoa à matignon et
lui font confiance on peut pas dire que
l'an 2 enfin le cas guy nadeau de manuel
macro s'ouvre dans la tranquillité et
avec l'adhésion massive des français
donc je ne pense pas que étant donné
cette situation extrêmement
délicate et complexe dans un contexte en
plus de crises économique et d'inflation
bientôt galopante sa préoccupation ne
soit de ne pas faire de peine à monsieur
dupont moretti débat sur dupond-moretti
débat aussi sur notre chat youtube
rangers power qui nous dit encore un
gouvernement fragile ça vaudra jamais un
gouvernement à la de gaulle et puis nos
grands hommes qui nous dit c'est très
solide quand même il répond à ranger
power c'est très solide quand même on a
pas mal de personnes passées par les
grandes écoles sauf à la santé et aux
armées oui la saga l'éducation de
l'assuré à l'éducation d'associer par la
filière littéraire dans mall sup jour
n'a pas parlé encore de de la santé
parce que non l'épidémie n'est pas finie
ou en tout cas l'annoncé n'a pas été
faite officiellement par le gouvernement
d'une épidémie de terminer brigitte
bourguignon elle était déjà dans le bain
gouvernement brugnon délégué chargé de
l'autonomie elle a les compétences doit
aller bien qu'est ce qu'elle va faire
qu'est ce qu'elle peut faire alors allez
socialiste
si elle était élue elle et lui dans le
pas de calais sous les couleurs
socialistes
elle est extrêmement importante à
l'assemblée nationale c'est une bûcheuse
est là elle a beaucoup oeuvré et
notamment sur la santé
pas sa langue dans sa poche
elle a language
pas du tout donc elle vous convainc pas
forcément politiquement mais en tout cas
sur la personne et sa personnalité
vous m'avez dit qu'elle était plutôt à
gauche et du parti socialiste ça c'est
pas forcément ce qu'il vous plaît
brigitte bourguignon ne sais pas ce que
j'ai dit bon allons faire mais non non
c'est vrai c'est une vraie femme de
gauche qui n'a pas sa langue dans sa
poche qui est parfaitement
consciente des enjeux
sanitaires dans ce pays et y compris de
la crise de la santé et la crise
hospitalière en particulier
qu'il y en a beaucoup parlé qui a
beaucoup travaillé dessus donc c'est
quand même un signe que avec elle en
tout cas emmanuel macron ne pourra pas
se contenter de sparadrap comme le ségur
de la santé si vous traitez ce mauvais
jeu de mots on va sur moi à découvrir
brigitte bourguignon quels sont les
types si vous deviez donner quelques
noms là les trois quatre noms qu'on va
surveiller dans les jours à venir leurs
premiers pas brigitte bourguignon
l'imaginent parce qu'on la connaît pas
outre avec notre percée d'alioui c'est
en attendant je vois pas c'est qu'il
avait donné une interview au monde ce
qui va vous faire rejoindre le propos de
julie sur l'existence d'un racisme
structurel en france c'est une thèse qui
peut racisme structurel qui est du
racisme en tout le monde est d'accord
culturel c'est la thèse du racisme
systémique dans l'eau sein de la société
free en suivant à mézigue des indigènes
ont soit très attentivement la passation
de pouvoir entre jean michel blanquer et
pas peine derrière ça ça va être très
intéressant le discours est bien terrien
le suit on le suit dupond-moretti
forcément aussi puisque c'est un
personnage qui n'a pas toujours sa
langue dans sa poche et moi je suivrai
fortement le nouveau ministre des
solidarités m'intéresse à damien abad
alors on suivrait fortement pour avoir
confirmation
du fait qu'il serait le chef de projet
de la réforme des retraites je me répète
un peu pardon et je trouve que c'est un
des enjeux politiques majeurs ce début
de quinquennat ministre des solidarités
de l'autonomie des personnes handicapées
damien abad judith vous vous suivez qui
trois personnes trois personnalités que
vous voulez particulièrement scruté dans
les jours qui viennent vous allez me
demander d'en prendre les différentes
juste pour le plaisir des mots parfois
effectivement pas taillé à sa saison vu
l'état de l'éducation nationale vu ses
prises de positions
indigènes ou compatibles
et vu le virage que ça représente un
carnet michel blanquer en terme de
défense de la glisse de la laïcité
pardon me paraît extrêmement important à
suivre
évidemment aussi d'amis à vaz il est
chargé du dossier des retraites que je
rappelle qu en fait
là pour l'instant
aux annonces démenti suivis d'annoncés
suivies de démentis on entendu
successivement finalement 65 ans ça
pouvait se discuter ça pouvait être 64
emmanuel macron lui même n'a pas écarté
l'idée d'un référendum pour savoir si on
a fait ou non cette fille je suis
réforme des retraites on est dans le
bleu le plus total et d'ailleurs de ce
point de vue là par rapport à ce qu'on
disait ou ce qu'on espérait avant que
l'annoncé du nouveau gouvernement soit
faite je trouve que le message politique
en termes d'attention qu'ils sont nés
cage est tout sauf claire à cause de ses
tourments d'accord avec vous à cause de
ces personnalités parce qu'on n'a pas
quelqu'un qui soit identifié un projet
qu'on connaît
on est dans le bleu comme on l'était
avant sur les intentions des manuels
matros c'est donc un gouvernement
parfaitement mac revient on pourra
trouver à peu près tous les sens le mans
même temps parfait seront sur un proche
atteint jamais imperfections qu'on se
rapproche parce que envoyer le signal
pas que n'diaye à la gauche voire à la
population allaient en france
la partie de la gauche qui s'est souvent
placé pour insulter la gauche mais c'est
un message en tout cas c'est un signal
fort un message envoyé à l'électorat de
droite dames en ag sur les retraites
avec l'entrée de de ce nouvel
nouvel élu de droite qui rejoint le
maquereau nice donc on a des signaux un
peu dans tous les sens sur l'écologie à
noter qu'on n'a pas un signal militants
écologistes vous l'avez déjà un seul
unissent du dit avec deux t on à
hsiaolin pour le technicien dover dans
l'avant-bras des noirs grande techno de
haut vol elisabeth baume mais qui ne
sont pas des personnalités politiquement
très enracinée donc on attend qu'ils ne
sont pas des idéologues ce qui est quand
même une bonne note alors ça peut être
une bonne nouvelle mais quand il va
falloir négocier des choses très
concrètes sur l'écologie qui changent la
vie quotidienne des gens là de faire un
peu de politique ne sera peut-être pas
inutile allez on a en hs cela est ce que
je lis crise creuse parce qu'il me dise
sur lefigaro.fr je lui dis tu as raison
on n'y comprend rien voilà donc ce qu'il
vous donne reste pas c'est pas faux on
est surpris mais on va en battant
premier conseil des ministres c'est
lundi quand même un dernier mot parce
qu'on a commencé avec elle catherine
colonna vous affaires étrangères c'est
confirmé pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
qui est elle parce qu'elle le sera aussi
tout de suite dans le vif du sujet avec
la situation en ukraine là pour le coup
c'est une décision moins surprenante
parce que c'est une grande
professionnelle 20 mois sur je pense que
moins surprenante en termes de qualité
produit là mais je veux dire catherine
colonna elle avait disparu de la vie
vous avez raison elle était entrée dans
la carrière diplomatique
mais c'est une grande professionnelle
certainement une des grandes un des
grands professionnels sur la place pour
mener une vie la plus libre diplomatie
française il faut noter au passage
qu'elle remplace qu'elle succède à jean
yves le drian qui est ministre depuis
dix ans puisqu'il avait été 50 ministre
de la défense sous françois hollande et
5 ans ministre des affaires étrangères
sous emmanuel macron rendons lui hommage
au passage parce que tout le monde n'a
pas été ministre disant du pape et
rappelons nous qu en fait il avait été
écarté de la défense et me aux affaires
étrangères certes parce qu'ils savaient
ils avaient les tout à fait les
compétences pour ce que je vaux
ministère mais aussi parce qu'être bercy
au budget on se plaignait du caractère
du côté très très dur en affaires de
jean yves le drian du temps où il était
à la défense et on voulait quelqu'un qui
soit - m florence parliez de ce point de
vue là était peut-être plus
compréhensives envers les mécanos
budgétaire les contraintes budgétaires
qui allait connaître habitants dont
gisèle ory sont florence parly où il
était très bon dans ce rôle florence
parly sort du gouvernement aussi après
ça servait c'était plutôt
l'annoncé l'avait annoncé d'ailleurs
dans les colonnes de clients envoyer une
photo avec les cartons derrière elle à
la loire yves partir être ministre de la
grande muette n'est pas forcément
toujours une fonction
fascina épanouissante et on n'en sort
pas avec beaucoup de loriol sauf qu'on a
géré une guerre sap a été le clac
florence panis mais les huées à gérer la
sortie du mali
qui se fait difficilement c'est un
euphémisme allez on fait le point pour
pour achever cela et si vous nous
rejoignez comme ça vous avez la liste
complète tenez vous prêts je commence
bruno le maire premier ministre non
attention premier nominé dénommé par
alexis connacht d'accord sur un
protocole me servais est extrêmement et
vous notez qu'il n'est pas ministre
d'état ministre
d'état non il n'y en a pas donc bruno le
maire ministre de l'économie des
finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et numérique vous vous étiez attachés au
ce mot à ce mauvais tour nté dit vous
avez noté qu'il était plusieurs fois
l'on va le rendre plusieurs fois mise de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin nistre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
catherine colonna garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice eric
dupond-moretti ministre des armées
sébastien lecornu qui passe donc de
l'outre-mer aux armées en remplacement
de florence parly ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires c'est amélie de
montchalin qui sera donc sous juste sous
elisabeth douarn qui elle est en charge
de l'écologie en plus de son poste de
premier ministre ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse et ça c'est
une surprise pap ndiaye qui vient de la
gauche c'est un historien il a 56 ans un
historien des minorités pas vraiment
dans la veine de jean michel blanquer
mais c'est bien lui qui lui succède au
ministère de l'éducation nationale
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
brigitte bourguignon qui était jusqu'ici
ministre délégué il me semble à
l'autonomie ministre du travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion c'est olivier
du soft ministre des solidarités de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
damien abad voilà pour les principaux
ministres ensuite mis à part la culture
non alors l'art la culture si elle était
elle a été nommée mais c'est vrai qu'il
est alors on l'a pas entendu vous avez
raison ries semble rim abdou le malade
c'est vrai qu'on va se pencher sur
laquelle l'agriculture parce que je ne
chanterai l'entente et qu'elle a été
nommée c'est tuer la conseillère de
culture et
kareem abdul malek qui est l'ancienne
conseillère culture d'emmanuel macron
dans les autres ministres parce que je
voulais je vous les donne quand même on
a aussi ministre délégué aux relations
avec le parlement olivier ferrand qui
reste donc au gouvernement
ministre délégué à l'égalité femmes
hommes et la diversité isabelle lovis
rome on verra on va découvrir qui elle
est ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics gabriel attal qui reste donc au
gouvernement ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales christophe
béchu nice délégué chargé de
l'attractivité du commerce extérieur
franck riester qui reste également au
gouvernement ministre délégué chargé de
l'europe il est secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes clément boon qui
reste donc la porte parole du
gouvernement c'est olivia grégoire
chargé de la mer secrétaire d'état
justine bénin chargée de l'enfance
charlotte comme elle chargée du
développement de la francophonie des
partenariats internationaux crise où la
zac auront pour nous alors je ne le
connais pas mais voilà on va la
découvrir ensemble et puis je note aussi
oudéa castéra c'est saab sur les bords
amélie oudéa castéra qui est la patronne
de roland garros me semble
non non non c'est la transition est bien
ici l'enjeu je rectifie elle est
directrice de la fédération française de
tennis voilà à quoi vous avez 23 nombre
c'est un peu longuet 23 c'est mon cas
mais que le gouvernement sortant on
avait près de 30 ministres en absolument
et ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
nous avait annoncé une première salve de
nominations sur les ministères d'une
case elle d'une quinzaine sur les
ministères structurants or on constate
que le que le couple exécutif
président et premier vice sont allés un
petit peu plus loin on nous annonce à
des mises et les gains des secrétaires
d'état pour un peu plus tard ici dizaine
de jours et finalement on en a
quelques-uns monde en a pas beaucoup oui
puis donc on paraissait pas tourisme on
n'a pas les pme on n'a pas le voilà pas
la mémoire on n'a pas citoyenneté le
poste de marlène schiappa disparu la
ville on a pas moins de dix ans à s'en
fait quelques dans le numérique tiens si
c'est bruno laisser dans ce portefeuille
de brut d'une image il y aura un
secrétaire d'état donc on peut quand
même attendre une deuxième vague de
secrétariat d'état ou de ministres
délégués dans les semaines qui viennent
mais ils ont quand même tenu un fichier
ensemble deux secrétaires d'état est de
mise les guette 10 17 nominations ce
vendredi après une semaine de suspense
haletant voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire sur
la nomination ça y est ce gouvernement
26 jours après après le
les la réélection des manuels macron
c'est un record ça n'avait jamais été vu
dans l'histoire de la vème république
mais ça n'avait jamais aussi était vu
qu'un résident soit réélu hors période
de cohabitation merci à tous les deux
merci beaucoup judith waintraub grand
reporter au figaro magazine c'était un
plaisir philippe guibert essayer de vous
revenez quand vous voulez merci à vous
ça vous fait plaisir oh bah oui c'est
bien pour nous c'est très bien plus
merci pour vos analyses on se retrouve
vite parce qu'on va suivre les
passations de pouvoir en y en a qui nous
intéresse tout particulièrement on suit
c'est leur éducation nationale mr et
puis il y aura des endroits ou non on
rempile pas de passation on pense à la
justice on pense à l'intérieur on pense
à l'économie à bientôt on se retrouve
très vite sur figaro live vous restez
sur lefigaro.fr il ya toutes les
informations au revoir